bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france vous réclamez la
désignation d'un expert judiciaire pour
faire la lumière sur les moyens qui sont
déployés par le réseau social pour un
modéré les tweets et ne qu'est ce qui
motive et cette assignation en justice
eh bien écoutez ce n'est pas la première
fois que nous nous faisons une procédure
de l'âme delà de la même aune en mai
2016 nous avions fait citer twitter pour
comprendre un peu comment marcher vous
ne marchez pas leurs dispositifs de
modération et au cours de leur instance
qui avait été rendue commune
cette société une mesure de médiation
avait été mis en place et un certain
nombre d'objectifs avait été affirmé
dans cette société notamment améliorer
la procédure le traitement des
signalements par exemple et nous avons
voulu vérifier ce qu'il en était des
bonnes dispositions de twitter selon
twitter or comme vous l'avez dit à
l'antenne à la suite en testing qui a
été effectué du 17 mars au 5 mai nous
nous sommes rendu compte que sur 1118
haineux seuls 12% ont été modérées par
twitter alors que parallèlement 67 9%
ont été modérées par la plateforme
facebook donc twitter est un peu le
cancre de le cancre débattent forme en
la matière et de plus nous avons
constaté comme vous l'avez dit à
l'antenne que healy à 45% de plus de
contenus racistes 20 % de contenu
antisémite en + 48 % de contenu
homophobes en plus tout cela explose sur
twitter et tout cela n'est pas
suffisamment modéré or ce que nous
demandons c'est à nouveau un la
désignation d'un expert qui aura pour
mission de se remettre tous les
documents afin de comprendre à la fois
les documents administratif contractuel
technique et humain ce qui a été mis en
oeuvre pour quoi cela était comment cela
l'a été et de comprendre quelles sont
les déficiences de cette société afin
qu'elle prenne cette fois ci les
dispositions qui s'imposent en vue de
modérer les signalements qui sont
envoyées
à cette plateforme lorsque des tweets et
ne sont référencés sur la plateforme en
question est justement très concrètement
vous espérez que l'assignation ou en
tout cas le fait de désigner un expert
judiciaire vous êtes vous espérez
concrètement que cela débouche sur
quelles nouvelles mesures et bien une
amélioration des dispositifs et des
obligations de twitter twitter à des
obligations qui sont inhérentes à ces sa
charte de fonctionnement et aussi à
l'éthique et à nos lois et à notre droit
donc si la modération n'est pas
suffisante
et s'il est 8eme se multiplient et que
la modération n'est pas fait comme elle
devrait
il faut qu'elles améliorent ces
dispositifs mais il faut préalablement
avant qu'un certain nombre de
propositions soient faites que nous
comprenions quels sont les déficiences
de cette plateforme
pourquoi elle ne remplit pas son job
qu'est ce qui cloche
en fait ça c'est ce qu'elle va nous
expliquer en vérité et ce pour quoi
ensuite un certain nombre de
propositions et ou d'obligations seront
faites afin de modérer en conséquence ce
qui doit l'être
merci beaucoup pour votre regard marqué
le nobel président de l'association un
j'accuse